that's not the plan
yeah it's crazy because you've obviously
I mean you know for you like you know
being able to kind of tell like the Pimp
C story in a way that is very
comprehensive very thorough
um do you kind of look at yourself as
like somebody who is like a historian of
of hip-hop at this point because you
were there for so much of an era that I
I think like
now we look back I don't you know I
always tell people like uh especially in
sports I'm like you don't realize like
what we're watching or what we're a part
of or what we're seeing on TV like you
don't know about like you're not gonna
appreciate LeBron until 10 years from
now when he's gone you know and I feel
like that era of Southern hip-hop and
everybody who came out of that who's
still relevant who are still I mean you
mentioned Rick Ross and cheesy and all
these people are just still Staples of
our culture like but you were like in
the just front row of the Reddit like
really the beginning of all of this
stuff
so do you kind of like I'm glad I was
there yeah I do consider myself a
historian I mean not honestly not just
for hip-hop but just I'm I'm into
history period right
um I really look at not only our time
period but just you know I have all
kinds of weird theories about like
even just how we live like our
lifestyles like people did not always
live this way we live I mean you know
I've been on some other like I'm off
adventuring like hiking and it just
makes you think about different um you
know people didn't always live like this
we don't really need like these big
houses and cars and stuff like there's
there's people who hey I've been
satisfied I dive down so many van life
YouTube rabbit holes where I'm just like
interested in seeing how people live in
a van so I live in a van did you know
that do you yes you van life I mean half
half I'm like I'm like 50 in sometimes
I'm like okay I gotta go to the BET
Awards weekend and do the interviews and
stuff but yeah I just I've just spent a
week in Yosemite in my van is it a van
or a sprinter it's not a sprinter it's a
uh ProMaster it's a cheaper Sprinter
sprinters out of my business so your van
is because okay I'm into this because
I've watched so many YouTubes so you
have like solar panels I thought you
brought that up because because you knew
that I had no idea so this is what
happened um I mean I've always been into
traveling but like 2020 I had all these
trips but like I had planned the whole
year out right so I went to Cape Town
January 2020 you go to Cape Town uh
forget where I went in February
somewhere else uh March I go to
Argentina Chile I was in Chile when Kobe
happened I mean it kind of when I flew
out of the U.S it was like you kind of
heard you heard about something
happening yeah yeah right but so I'm in
the middle of nowhere like you could
only get service like once a day so like
every day I'm getting like a few texts
and my friends are like uh things are
getting canceled you probably should
come home yeah like I don't know if
you're gonna go get back in that's
really what happened so I was on one of
the last flights back to Atlanta before
they shut everything down I got back to
the airport and the airport is
completely empty and I'm like
The Crazies drive on the freeway like no
one's on cars I'm like so abruptly I'm
like my whole year is just I gotta
cancel everything yeah what's what's
gonna happen so I'm just bored watching
down this rabbit hole for like two weeks
of YouTube videos and I'm like you know
what I could do that yeah bought a cargo
van and I'm like
okay now I'm committed uh now I got to
build this thing so I built a camper van
during so in your van do you have like
the uh like a little sink and a little
like you could cook in there and I
learned so much I mean I could I feel
like I could really build a house now
maybe I couldn't but um yeah I have two
I have solar panels I have a whole desk
I have satellite internet I have do you
have the uh do you have this yeah the
Starling yeah does the starlink work I'm
not really Elon fan yes the starlink
works it does not work if there's trees
you have to have a clear a clear clear
view of the Horizon wow and last year it
didn't work past a certain I went to the
Arctic Ocean last year and it didn't
work past a certain how do you get to
the Arctic Ocean I drove to the Arctic
Ocean where is that it's at the very top
of the continent
like look at where I am so it's like the
top of Canada yes
there's only one place you can drive to
the ocean and it's this little Indian
well I don't say Indian they call it
first nation in Canada yeah Native
American uh Canadians and it's called Uh
Hamlet since they don't call it a city
but um it was a very interesting place I
met some like like some little girls
came out we're talking to me do you have
a pet no okay I just got because you
know you'll see these guys online they
always have a little dog with them you
know I've considered it you know dogs
are not really welcome at all the parks
because they tend to tear up the
ecosystem is what they they're very
destructive to the ecosystem is what
I've been told so I don't really want so
you're you're you're
a nomad absolutely yes so it took me a
year and a half to build the van so I
mean and by this time like the world has
sort of started to return to normal and
now I'm like now I have like now I'm in
this bad job I have to finish it was a
lot of work I can imagine you watch the
Youtube videos and you're like okay cool
but that those YouTube videos make it
seem so easy right absolutely do yeah
you'll be like damn this guy did this in
four hours or something like
it's a lot of work but I I think
probably I mean the first one is the
hardest because you're like there's a
learning curve with everything but um so
yeah I love it yeah yeah so you love it
so you're pretty much for you on a
normal basis when like you're in town
for BT Awards right it just happened
right for you though like I don't know I
do not do the van in cities
I will say I'm not I'm not in the van in
L.A I mean if you're in a van in La you
are just homeless if you're in a van and
if you're in a van in San Francisco San
Francisco you're homeless homeless yeah
if you're in a woman now now if you're
in but you're if you're in like the
desert in Utah or if you're at the
Arctic Ocean then you're [__] cool
because you I spent the night at the
edge of the Arctic Ocean watching the
Northern Lights cook myself dinner and
took a shower in the van that I built
that's Peak like that's amazing well I
was gonna ask you like um
where does the van stay
um her name is Carmen van Diego okay
she's a she where does she stay
um she's a nomad so she like because
you're obviously a home base for use the
south is it Atlanta Atlanta yeah so is
the van just you got a spot you got like
a little no
um that's a terrible drive to I keep it
out anywhere out west okay I found an
airport with uh so do you have parking
do you have an uh like an apartment
but I have a house okay so you have a
house I'm not I'm not totally down the
rabbit hole wow yeah that's pretty sick
so you've seen some pretty uh but you
know what I don't know how much longer
I'll keep it though because it's it's
tempting to just be like yeah let me
just well because you could probably
sell that thing for a serious amount of
change because people people would
rather not do what you did yeah well you
know but people really aren't uh no I'm
talking about the house if I was gonna
sell anything else
I mean it's not a bad idea
it's not a bad idea I'm intrigued by the
family no it is I mean it is nice to
have a
a place to go back to this
permanent for sure for sure keep some
things but I think I could do the van
life full time I really was like
dedicated to it but you guys have seen
some crazy [__] though just traveling
the country
let me think I mean going to the Arctic
Ocean was definitely has anyone tried to
break in
come on now don't don't bring that on I
don't know I don't know you're at a
truck stop there's weird like I said I
will not go to I won't go to San
Francisco I won't go to La
um right I'll leave it somewhere else
and fly to the city I don't I don't do
the big cities that's pretty cool
um so I mean so far I've
not gonna say I haven't had any crazy
experiences but yeah it's
um that's the that's so that's the two
questions men ask about the van where's
your weapon have you had sex in the van
those are the two questions do you have
a weapon in there
I did get a cool I saw a cool front
plate that this guy had has said if the
van is rocking don't come knocking so I
got one just because I thought it was
cool shout out to the van life
the activation
it's a long drive
um it depends on where you're starting
from obviously but the the road itself
it's an 18 hour
dirt washboard Road it's terrible
terrible that sounds cool that's once
you yeah you're all the way in Northern
Yukon so the crazy thing is
I almost got stuck there like well I did
get stuck there but it was there's one
road only one way up and down and so
I was driving up and it's it's beautiful
like it's the scenery is amazing but
it's and it's quiet but it's not quiet
at the point where you could just stop
your car and get out of the car and it's
also you can't leave the road because
it's permafrost so the road is like
specially designed so if you if you pull
this heavy van off the road you're gonna
just sink into the ground because it's
it's permafrost so you can't leave the
road you can't really get out of the car
so I'm like this whole 18 hours I'm like
I wish I could I have got my camera my
drone I'm like this is [__] beautiful
like I can't even can't even get out and
stop yeah so I get up there it was it
was amazing when I I 60 degrees
I swam in the Arctic Ocean like I said
like how cold was that
it really wasn't as cold as as you would
think as I thought it would be great I
just swam in it just to be like I did I
did I came all this way I might as well
get in spent the night saw the Northern
Lights it's incredible up there because
you're so far north they're like above
you right so I just was like this all
night just watching the lights or
whatever so next day I started driving
back down and there's there's also like
Ferry Crossings there's something about
they can't support the bridges because
of the permafrost or whatever so you
have to take fairies at certain points
so I'm on the ferry and the guy in the
ferry is like hey did you hear the
bridge is closed
and I'm like no and he's like yeah the
bridge is closed so there's a bridge
halfway so it's like mile or hour nine
of this 18 hour journey and I guess
there was a construction happening this
guy had his boom up on the construction
truck and he hit the bridge
so
the Canadian government or whatever puts
out this alert that's like and you you
don't have service up there because the
Starling didn't didn't work up there at
all well um I think it does now but
there's there was like one spot where I
could get a signal and so I you know get
to this one spot it's like a higher
point or whatever and
check online and it says Bridges close
for 30 days
and I'm like uh yeah I kind of can't
really hang out in the I'm above the
Arctic Circle like it's and it's like
September or something like it's gonna
it turns you know really fast it gets
cold and so I'm like freaking out like
sorry definitely freaked out there was
like 20 maybe like 20 of us in RVs and
stuff that were above the arc Circle so
you it was interesting it was like a
throwback to like the old days where you
didn't have social media right and stuff
like that so you if you see anyone
driving around here like hey have you
heard anything like because it's it's
there is a small town so it's not like
you're just totally but you know they're
they get their supplies from down there
too so they're like how are we gonna get
gas how are we gonna get food
so it ended up being so three days later
they had to have like Engineers come up
from the big city and you know white
horse or whatever and they analyzed like
is it safe so we ended up getting to
cross three days later they had all
these Engineers out there and they're
like one at a time and they did all
these calculations on it the bridge was
you know sturdy or not so for three days
it was Labor Day weekend actually
so Labor Day weekend and it finally
dawned on me I'm like this is my [__]
dream like why am I mad about this like
I get this whole area to myself right no
one's yeah so I got the Drone out I'm
like driving everywhere that's that's
fire I know it makes me sound like a
nerd because most people would be like
no that's just not into this but I
thought it was [__] awesome so I got
to spend my Labor Day weekend
driving around the Arctic with my
cameras and my drone took all these cool
pictures and then they were like go
ahead you can go home I like that that
was probably my best van Life Adventure
yet